washington post columnist is slamming
the comedian in an op-ed
quote jon stewart's rant is a reminder
don't rely on celebrities for coven 19
theories
and the former head of the cdc not
backing away from his belief on where
kobet came from
i don't think it's plausible that
this virus went from a bat
to an animal we still don't know that
animal
and then went into humans and
immediately had learned how to be human
to human transmissible to the point of
now
causing one of the greatest pandemics
we've had in the history of the world
so some say he might not have been
telling the truth and he might have been
joking greg you've got a good handle on
seriousness and comedy was it was he
telling the truth or yeah i think the
big revelation here is that jon stewart
watches fox news
because this is exactly what we've been
saying at this table for a while and it
makes sense he's now
in our age group where the wisdom kicks
in or maybe his writer because
i think it was this show at the gutfelt
show when i said uh when there's a
firework explosion in a small town
you check the fireworks factory and then
his writer wrote something about if
there's a chocolate
explosion you check the chocolate
factory so i think this was so shocking
to colbert and others is because they
live in a bubble
and they haven't heard this opinion
whereas you've heard this opinion and
other opinions here on fox in fact we've
talked about this plausible theory
we've done we've done segments on it but
in places like the view
where the only information they get is
from people magazine uh they're like oh
my god this is so amazing
it's just anybody that was shocked by
this reveals the ignorance
of the actual topic dana you know
white houses have to be able to respond
when bad things happen to try to make
sure
we're prepared are we i'm assuming that
china unless they let us in
you have to assume the worst case i
think you have to i think that's right i
think you have to assume the worst and
china needs to know that we all assume
the worst like for and the left is
confusing so if this were called the
moscow virus
and then it all started in moscow do you
think that they would be like reluctant
to find out the root cause of like
how this virus got out there and to dr
redfield's point one of the big problems
early on is that
because china wasn't open about what was
going on here
we were treating the cdc was treating
this as another sars outbreak which is
you treat sars in a different way than
you treat coronaviruses
so a white house or an administration if
they don't have clear information you're
going to maybe treat the wrong problem
and that's possibly you know lost us
some time and led to a lot of people
losing their lives and their livelihoods
and so i
just wonder like when is the left gonna
get mad well speaking of the left
getting mad
jesse you have a what
did i make them mad again i think this
is safe
this is funny it's common sense but it's
safe
we've known for a year it likely came
from a lab biden now
says it's okay to talk about fauci in
the washington post and cnn
say this is okay to talk about so then
he cracks a joke about the lab
and the left says ooh bold this is edgy
he went there
he didn't go there the guy's retired the
only reason he makes a joke like this is
because he doesn't work for the
corporate media
when you work for the corporate media
you can't cut against the narrative
the narrative was this can't come from a
lab because they have so much
money over there invested in beijing
time warner atnt
comcast they're not going to send a team
of investigators
over to the wuhan lab and start poking
around there's too much at stake
chinese will just take away their
license and their deals and their
contracts
and it's over so you can't even say
something
that's obvious if that is is
it goes against the profit margins look
they did it with smolette
smileth the type of guy at midnight and
below freezing gonna go out for a subway
sandwich
you would you say that they call you a
racist remember
or what about kavanaugh does it really
strike me as a gang rapist
oh no you can't say that that's sexist
and now you know do the chinese are they
really giving hunter biden a diamond
because they're best friends
no it's a bribe but if you say something
the corporate media doesn't like because
it interferes with their bottom line
their ex communicate you he doesn't have
to deal with that anymore because he's
retired and he works on a farm
now does he yeah he has a little farm oh
no wonder the beard yes he's in
character
how should how should the business
community what should they be urging
president biden to do with china oh
they're in the bag with the communist
party of china if the if any company
wants to do business in china they're
carrying water for xi jinping at all and
that's what's so disgusting and
you've seen it with like complete uh
reticence to call out um well human
rights abuses
in china so greg i have to apologize to
you i think i stole that
that line from you too you didn't know
it and i feel like i feel
we we both did it we shared that i
shared the same
thought oh i like that um
i but i want to take my take on this is
that this is
jon stewart beginning to reclaim comedy
in a way
that because it's been held hostage by
thin skinned liberals i hope you're
right
and so you cannot write jokes
that land around the micro sensitivities
of a bunch of left wing nuts
so he goes on colbert knowing that
colbert
he made that guy's career although it
seems to be
you know spiraling downward a toilet
bowl given the
lack of laughs on that late night show
but there is
nothing funnier than a comic ridiculing
uh knocking the stuff in out of a
sour arrogant self-important blowhard
joan rivers did it
don rickles did it and there is no
bigger sour
self-important arrogant blowhard than
stephen colbert
and jon stewart did it right in front of
him i basically threw it in his face
and i ate it up but i won't be watching
that show watch greg gofeld every night
though there you go
it's gonna be great tonight i didn't
even know there were other guys on it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else